[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas de visual
política la amistad y la alianza
política y militar entre los eeuu y
corea del sur ha sido desde el fin de la
segunda guerra mundial junto a japón la
piedra angular de la diplomacia
estadounidense en toda asia
cuando se firmó el armisticio de la
guerra de corea en 1953 este país
formaba parte de un pequeño eje alineado
con eeuu y rodeado por enormes potencias
comunistas la unión soviética y la
república popular china
[Música]
un eje que con ella formaba junto a
japón y taiwán claro que de estos tres
países son lo corea del sur está el
suelo continental y lo que resulta aún
mucho más importante es el país más
próximo a la zona más rica e importante
política económica y militarmente de
toda china el eje pekín shanghai
por este motivo no puede resultarnos
extraño que corea del sur haya sido
siempre una prioridad geopolítica para
los eeuu al tiempo que para los
surcoreanos la protección que les ha
brindado estar bajo el paraguas de la
mayor potencia militar del mundo también
ha sido un balón de oxígeno toda una
garantía para su seguridad nacional por
así decirlo en materia político y
militar ésta ha sido una relación
simbiótica sin embargo en materia
económica el camino ha sido algo más
difuso hasta los años 80 corea del sur-
fue muy dependiente de eeuu por ejemplo
en 1970 las exportaciones importaciones
con eeuu y japón
representaban más del 70 por ciento de
todo el comercio surcoreano una cifra
que a partir de la década de los 80
comenzó a descender paulatinamente
gracias en parte a la emergencia de
china el gigante asiático el país de los
tres reyes eso y con mucha diferencia el
mayor socio comercial de corea del sur
[Música]
pero un momento porque los lazos
económicos no es lo único que se ha
difuminado en la relación entre corea
del sur y eeuu el conocido como el país
de la mañana tranquila lleva años
haciendo equilibrios entre lo que es
bueno para su seguridad nacional que lo
inclina hacia los eeuu y lo que es bueno
para su economía y sus empresas que lo
decanta hacia china
[Música]
corea del sur atrapada en medio mientras
los gigante china y eeuu se enfrentan
para verlo más claro casi que podemos
decir que corea del sur ha ido
desplazándose hasta situarse en el
centro de una bulliciosa sala que tiene
en una esquina a eeuu ya china en la
esquina opuesta mientras las dos
superpotencias se llaman de todo a
gritos
[Aplausos]
ese es más o menos el reto al que se
enfrenta la diplomacia surcoreana
respecto a los dos gigantes del mundo
moderno claro que la creciente
influencia de china no es ni de lejos lo
único que explica el deterioro que han
sufrido las relaciones entre eeuu y
corea del sur pero que ha llevado a la
tradicional historia de amor entre seúl
y washington al punto más bajo que
podemos recordar puede la llegada de joe
biden a la casa blanca recomponer esta
vieja relación atentos
una alianza con mucha tensión
[Música]
desde que soy sin pin se hizo con las
riendas de china en el año 2013 uno de
sus campos de batalla prioritarios
además de extender el poder de china en
el mundo ha sido precisamente debilitar
las alianzas estratégicas los eeuu
[Música]
y como con japón lo tienen muy
complicado por las viejas rencillas
históricas y políticas con china cuerda
del sur ha sido el principal objetivo en
el punto de mira
ahora bien no nos engañemos el principal
escollo en las relaciones entre eeuu y
corea no ha sido siguen ping sino los
propios estados unidos de américa en
particular el 45º presidente
norteamericano donald trump
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando a ver
camps otra vez trump es que acaso hay
que echarle la culpa de todo pues no de
todo todo evidentemente no pero qué
queréis que os diga en esta historia su
protagonismo fue decisivo
las relaciones entre corea del sur y
eeuu han sido muy estrechas actualmente
unos 28.500 soldados norteamericanos
siguen desplegados en el país asiático
un despliegue que hasta comienzos de la
década de los 90 incluyó también armas
nucleares no olvidéis que corea del sur
es un país que junto con japón está
protegido bajo el llamado paraguas
nuclear una estrategia que he llegado al
caso permitiría a eeuu realizar un
ataque nuclear rápido en caso de que se
produjera un ataque contra el territorio
surcoreano
[Música]
y eso no es todo en cuerda del seguro
también está desplegado el escudo
antimisiles estadounidense chad un
escudo que durante su despliegue provocó
una enorme crisis diplomática entre
china y corea con boicot comercial chino
incluido lo que como ya os hemos contado
en alguna que otra ocasión le causó a la
economía surcoreana importantes daños
económicos además el país de la mañana
tranquila es también uno de los
principales puntos estratégicos de
escala para la marina norteamericana en
asia-pacífico así que claro con todo
esto que estamos contando lo lógico es
que llegado este momento pensáis para
ver a alberto entonces quién me estás
contando qué problema hay con la alianza
entre surcoreanos y estadounidenses pues
bien como os decíamos antes es justo
ahora cuando nos toca hablar otra vez
del ya ex presidente
donald trump
[Música]
con la llegada de donald trump al
despacho oval cambiaron muchas cosas
entre ellas la forma mediante la cual
eeuu se ha estado relacionando con sus
países aliados durante sus cuatro años
de mandato a tramp el tema de las
alianzas y su influencia en el
equilibrio político mundial no le
importó prácticamente nada su obsesión
fue centrarse casi en exclusiva en dos
cosas por un lado reducir los costes de
los despliegues militares permanentes en
el extranjero y por otro equilibrar la
tan famosa balanza comercial
[Música]
y por supuesto corea del sur no se libró
de la furia con la que trump trató a
muchos de los más importantes aliados de
los eeuu por ejemplo poco después de
llegar al poder trump decidió
unilateralmente que había que modificar
el tratado de libre comercio corea eeuu
el conocido como tlc chorus que en su
campaña electoral llegó a pintar como un
acuerdo que mata empleos de hecho un par
de meses antes de sentarse a acordar los
nuevos términos trump lanzó la sección
201 que fijaba aranceles a las lavadoras
y los paneles solares lo que afectaba
particularmente a corea china y corea
del sur protestan por los aranceles a
las lavadoras y los paneles solares de
hecho este movimiento fue visto casi
como una forma de extorsión para
renegociar los términos del tlc chorus
un acuerdo firmado en 2007 por la
administración republicana de george
bush y que no había entrado en vigor
hasta el 2012 si lo habéis escuchado
bien trump desencadenó su ira contra una
acuerdo que supuestamente había
contribuido al desmantelamiento
industrial que eeuu lleva padeciendo
décadas a pesar de llevar apenas cuatro
años en vigor
en cualquier caso digamos que la casa
blanca tampoco es que consiguiera
demasiado con su campaña de acoso y
derribo fue más bien toda una campaña de
imagen de trump para tratar de vender
todos los éxitos a sus votantes por
ejemplo una de las claves de la
renegociación firmada en marzo de 2018
fue aumentar de 25.000 a 50.000 el
número máximo de vehículos americanos
que se podían exportar a corea del sur-
sin tener que ser aprobados de nuevo por
los reguladores coreanos el pequeño
detalle es que en ese momento eeuu
llevaba ya seis años sin alcanzar esos
25 mil vehículos libres de revisión de
hecho ford y general motors habían
exportado menos de 10.000 bajo esta
figura al año anterior así que podéis
imaginar cambiar un máximo que nos
alcanzaba añadía previsión de hacerlo
pues es básicamente algo vacío pero la
presión de trump contra corea no terminó
aquí poco después en 2019 también
amenazó de nuevo con imponer aranceles
de hasta el 25 por ciento a los coches
surcoreanos y ojo porque esto sí que
podría haber sido un buen pellizco ya
que las exportaciones de vehículos
al sur a eeuu ascendieron a 13 mil 600
millones de dólares en 2018 y claro la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cómo
demonios es posible que eeuu decidiera
ser tan hostil con un aliado tan
estrecho importante no podría acaso toda
esta presión hacer que corea del sur
estrechará aún más sus lazos con china
qué sentido tiene poner en marcha una
política y un discurso de amenazas tan
duro cuando no tienes que ganar y mucho
que perder no se supone quien limitar la
influencia de china era la pérdida de
número 1 en fin incongruencias del
américa first y ojo porque si pensáis
que la obsesión de trump contra corea
del sur se limitó sólo al campo
comercial estáis muy equivocados os
hemos contado en korea hay desplegados
28 mil 500 soldados norteamericanos cuyo
puesto se reparte entre ambos países
pues bien desde 2018 este fue también
otro de los campos de batalla de trump y
es que
el 31 de diciembre de ese año expiraba
el anterior acuerdo de costes así que
trump vio su oportunidad para sacar más
dinero y apuntarse un tanto entre su
electorado hablamos precisamente de poco
de enero frank quería que corea del sur
pasase de pagar 5 mil millones de
dólares cada año frente a los
aproximadamente 850 que venía pagando
anteriormente es decir tram ponía sobre
la mesa un aumento de casi el 600 por
ciento aún a sabiendas de que eso sería
algo inaceptable para seúl y que entre
otras cosas violaba el acuerdo sobre el
estatus de las fuerzas de 1.966 cuyo
artículo 5 dice que eeuu corre con los
costes de despliegue excepto cuestiones
como suministros y derechos de paso para
hacer fuerza al ex presidente de eeuu no
dudó en amenazar a corea con la retirada
de todas sus tropas algo que hubiera
hecho muy pero que muy felices a los
gobiernos de china y corea del norte
en fin los famosos órdagos de trump
cuanto nos vamos a echar de menos en
visual político el caso es que aunque el
logo trump rebajó su exigencia hasta los
1.300 millones tampoco se llegó a ningún
acuerdo con seúl y así se quedó la cosa
hasta que vai bien volver a mover el
asunto en febrero del 2021 acercándose
ahora sí a un acuerdo 9 de marzo de 2021
en corea del sur- by tim pone fin a la
disputa de tram por la participación
militar en los costos el departamento de
estado dijo que el acuerdo se extendería
hasta 2025 e incluiría un aumento
importante en los pagos asumidos por
corea del sur para apoyar el despliegue
de tropas estadounidenses el problema es
que todos estos órdagos amenazas
guerrillas comerciales y malas maneras
entre el gobierno de eeuu y corea del
sur durante la presidencia de trump han
erosionado mucho la confianza de la casa
azul y de los surcoreanos hacia su
histórico aliado además ver como al
mismo tiempo trump se codeaba con quien
ningún entre sonrisas llamándole amigo y
persona talentosa entre otros muchos
piropos
ayuda a la hora de conservar la
confianza y la credibilidad aunque bueno
para ser justos el presidente mucho
tampoco se quedó muy atrás en eso
pero no nos desviemos el caso es que los
cuatro años de trump constituyen una
parte importante del por qué ahora corea
del sur ha comenzado a considerar qué
apostarlo todo a eeuu podría ser un
enorme error que a ser posible hay que
tener más cartas en la mesa
de tal forma que lo que ha pasado es que
a día de hoy según está intentando
mantener una posición de equidistancia
entre eeuu y china
llegando a mantenerse al margen de los
temas más sensibles para pekín como por
ejemplo el asalto a hong kong o las
disputas de las islas artificiales en el
mar de la china meridional
[Música]
ahora bien la pregunta que debemos
hacernos llegados a este punto es puede
eeuu a recuperar la credibilidad en
korea y restaurar la influencia que ha
perdido pues bien con la llegada de
bailén se abre un atisbo de cambio en
toda esta historia un cambio que sin
embargo está envuelto en todo un halo de
incertidumbre quiere saber por qué
pues bien veámoslo
la incertidumbre que mancha una bonita
amistad
queridos amigos la llegada de joe vaivén
a la casa blanca ha estado marcada por
su promesa de recuperar la conocida como
bucks americana especialmente en lo que
incumbe a los aliados más importantes
para los eeuu américa está de vuelta la
diplomacia está de vuelta cuando
reforzamos nuestras alianzas ampliamos
nuestro poder así como nuestra capacidad
para evitar amenazas antes de que
lleguen a nuestras costas américa no
puede permitirse estar ausente por más
tiempo en el plano internacional
joe biden presidente de eeuu si unas
palabras muy bonitas pero de qué forma
podría bailén reencaminar las relaciones
con su aliado surcoreano pues bien
aunque parezca contraproducente lo
cierto es que su apuesta pasa
precisamente por china
bailén quiere crear una especie de club
de democracias aliadas que sea capaz de
contrarrestar el poder de china actuando
de forma multilateral algo así como un
todos para uno y uno para todos con el
que frenar a pekín un club en el que
evidentemente corea del sur una de las
democracias más importantes de asia
podría tener mucho que decir claro que
esto suena tan bonito como difícil de
llevar a cabo porque iba a un país como
cara del sur a jugarse sus relaciones
económicas con china para volver a ir de
la mano de otro país del que ya no se
fía tanto
[Música]
pues ojo porque en el horizonte hay una
ventana de oportunidad mucho dejará la
presidencia en mayo del 2022 no es que
seamos adivinos es que en cora del sur
no existe la reelección y ahora de hoy
la oposición conservadora mucho más
cercana a eeuu y composiciones más
hostiles hacia china tiene posibilidades
de ganar así que lo que toca en este
caso es esperar esperar primero a ver
qué pasos va tomando vaivén en los
próximos meses respecto a china y sus
aliados en asia y después esperar sobre
qué pasa en las elecciones surcoreanas
del año que viene
lo que está claro es que ahora la
administración de joe biden tiene tiempo
como para intentar que la llama del amor
vuelva a crecer y ojo porque corea del
sur es para eeuu clave si la potencia
norteamericana aspira a mantener su
papel en la región de asia-pacífico en
el nuevo eje económico y político del
mundo la pregunta es será capaz de
volver a encandilar a su viejo aliado
podrá washington lograr que -según rompa
con una estrategia pragmática que le
está funcionando muy bien para volver a
ir de la mano déjanos tus respuestas en
los comentarios ya sabes si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle al botón de like i suscribirte a
visual política un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]